plus d'une semaine est passée depuis la
catastrophe dans le port de beyrouth une
semaine khasan alcoa qui attend des
nouvelles de son fils rami l'un des
pompiers arrivés quelques secondes avant
les explosions
je lui ai dit fais attention mon fils
soient toujours attentif si quelque
chose se passe quelque part s'il ya un
incendie il faut être prudent et en
alerte
il m'a dit de s'en remettre à jim que
les coeurs de tous les responsables se
consume ça va je prie dieu que cela
arrive à leur fille et à toute leur
famille par ailleurs les jours et les
heures s'écoulent lentement pour cette
famille dans l'attenté d'un miracle
depuis la catastrophe la fille de rami
trois ans est pris en charge par son
frère une fille qui ne cesse de se
demander où est son père sa fille est
très attaché à lui chaque jour et nous
envoyer au moins trois vidéos avec elle
il a filmé et nous l'envoyer ou jouer
avec elle ils adorent et je jure devant
dieu je ne peux revoir ou même à une
seule tout est entre les mains de dieu
maintenant je pleure quand je suis seul
mais je ne pleure pas de voir le signe
il se sentirait très triste et font nous
attendons des informations depuis six
jours nous attendons même la nouvelle la
plus effrayante
rabat ce moment est difficile très
difficile mais nous avons tous de
l'espoir un espoir qui s'érode au fil
des heures les ruines encore visibles
ont mis fin à de nombreuses vies et
plongé dans la souffrance
de nombreuses familles libanaises